l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj che non ci siamo
su troppi square ragazzi tra il face
questo è un gioco e famosissimo gioco in
flash alimenti consiste nel cercare di
passare dei livelli
la corsa per quanto difficile in quanto
il gioco tenterà di trovarti in tutti i
modi possibili e ormai da mesi ragazzi
che vi considerate sta roba ma non avevo
ancora fatta perché diciamo che a
claudia vitale in tutti i modi ma tanto
lo sapevo che prima o poi avrei dovuto
farla per forza quindi iniziamo da gi
tua che ti ho chiesto di un ex loro
poiché i ragazzi dopo devo spegnere la
televisione per passare al prossimo
livello quindi non tagliare cavo giusto
o quello blu sapevo che era quello rosso
[ __ ] ci avrei scommesso qualsiasi
cosa va dai come primo tentativo è
andato a casa è possibile
dopo lo verde non è quello verso quella
singola televisione titolo subito ma non
è così non penso sia il caos testo vero
chiaro non vengano
[Risate]
cazzo dedicata liman attestata ragazzi
sta cosa non mi devo scegliere no non ci
credo
pil a villa rosa fino alla blu pillola
rossa
ragazzi siamo non era perfetto ragazzi a
50 50 io valgo senza [ __ ] non era
neanche quella blu allora probabilmente
lo cliccare qualcos'altro che non l'ho
vista ma perché sto gioco è tutto così
ragazzi ciechi trolla in un'accusa
l'occhio ragazzi sa cosa non l'ho capita
ma andiamo avanti
ti scappa da fish eye della situazione
in cui si trovano tutti i quadri e bagno
delle ragazze che è chiuso quindi il
bagno del blog i ragazzi siamo sicuri
che quello al vaglio degli uomini ai
miei copie allora abbiamo la chiave la
chiave per entrare nel bagno perché york
ragazzi sta cosa non la capirò mai che
ti devi infilare la chiave nell'occhio
cos'è cos'è star ma [ __ ] ragazzi
sto a livello non ha un senso dove devo
cliccare allora abbiamo capito devo
farmene addosso gli occhi il gatto tutta
la serratura è chiusa chiusa a chiave ma
porca [ __ ] costa chiave nell'occhio
se mi parlò prima l'occhio no o forse
quando chiude gli occhi fatto ma dovevo
cambiare baba senti job è in questo caso
di bagno per favore io so gioca ragazzi
andrò ad odiarlo in una maniera che non
avete idea cosa si è messo in testa
questo 76 sta roba
devo andare ad hoc e cappello
concatenare i propri
la cosa non è giusto
sì ma cazzo ho vinto ho vinto su non mi
capitava meglio di vincere subito credo
ok ragazzi già stiamo facendo questa
questa non ce l'ho fatta non hai capito
cosa è successo effettivamente ma sto
andando a fuoco
e la cosa non va bene che cosa devo fare
ogni anno le frecce sono bellissime
libici hanno addosso tattico ed ai
ragazzi sto gioco non ha potuto senza ma
chi se ne frega
allora devo il torero il torero un libro
ragazzi sta cosa fantastica devo allora
facciamo così se io lo tengo rosso si in
pista c'è torero arrosto
no come re start ho perso come cazzo
fatto perdere sarà invece di paste
troiate ma fatti una pippa maledizione
devo a questo è un mago che mi trasformo
in qualsiasi cosa devo fare
cosa devo cliccare berni la bacchetta
soca amy adesso di trasforma in un ok
avrei preferito
no non la ho vinto la meno costosa è
quella roba lì via parte parti veloce
veloce prima che arrivi ragazzi sta
alimentando la cosa o se cos'è sta roba
perché qual è il senso visto che di
giorno ragazzi che prima di finire sto
gioco vado a denunciare effettivamente
chi l'ha creato si è fermato il cuore
liechtenstein soft troll penso che devo
toccare dieci volte sulla troll face 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 fottutamente 10 quella sul
tasto
[Musica]
che level failed ma cosa sbaglio se
tutto nove dieci professori di
maledizione giusta vedo che c'è ragazzi
ci sono di nuovo credo sia questo
altrove dove devo scaricare 10 volte
tipo così e soddisfazione dopo rari fare
tutto quanto
cosa devo cos'è sta roba 50 50
telefonate a casa 50 50 ok
effettivamente era meglio la telefonata
a casa
ok forse no devo casaro neanche sulla
roccia del cazzo che stavo fare qui per
me mappa e massi certo la condizione di
più laico ma ce lo stop la wing la pappa
col gioco mi danno il vostro pc di kit
mario lega ma se lo fa deve andare alla
fine può portare anche alla bella alla
fine perfetto qualcosa mi dice che non è
così facile però congratulation click
l'ex label congratula allora devo
ritornare indietro e poi cliccarci
sporca [ __ ] chi se lo ricorda la
strada di aspettare allora piano
e possibile anci volume mi sia scontato
il mouse fantastico alla ragazzi non ho
ben capito dove devo andare come faccio
a raggiungerlo ma se fuori come devo
passare per il like the viari non è
difficile non è sì ok ci siamo la
ragazzi devo passare chi fuori e andare
qui lo cliccati grazia grazie a dio
grazie a dio cosa devo schivare gli
ostacoli perfetto non ha questo mi
sembra più semplice
sono arrivato alla stanza vanno io non
come faccio qui come cazzo dovevi fare
qui prega i livelli stanno diventando un
macello io ve lo dico ma come dovrei
fare nervoso sta roba che un nave teater
cosa devo fare qui non mi raggiungerà
istanza aiuto
vabbè click al bottone larga 100 volte
sì certo come se non si riuscisse
veramente ragazzi sta alimentando
addossate la cosa aspettate che al 50 mi
fermo perché ho paura che succeda
qualcosa
no non è successo niente perfetto
secondamano.it andrei piano perché ho
paura che mi vota no chi si gioca non mi
chiama ho vinto ho vinto in una maniera
incredibile
mamma mia come lo [ __ ] in culo te lo
devi mettere sto bottone devo bere
questa qui all ala sinistra non voglio
sempre perchè perchè uno che sta per
essere schiacciato deve bere
qual è l'utilità di bere ma voglio con
tutte dovrà funzionare qualcosa ma
l'iniziale c'è qualcosa di sicuro che
non vedo perché non è possibile tipo
qualcosa di non sposavo
luca ragazzi non ci credo è stato trova
il 10 tra il face in 10 secondi
allora 12 queste valgono come trofei su
nove fermi 1234567 ma non è solo questo
78 aiuto dov'è quel 93 l'ultima cazzo
dov'è 10 tutto avete iniziato a
chiamarmi share lo credo che non ha
veramente senso che ci è riuscito a fare
una cosa del genere
ok perfetto come non detto devo saltare
il tasso di salto quale perfetto ciao
c'è una coordinazione di salto che fa
veramente spavento sto tizio ragazzo
gioco ci tengo a dire che è meraviglioso
ringrazio di cuore chi me l'ha
consigliato e aspetta che ti trovi in
giro chi cazzo è successo non devo
prendere jump alla fine non perché se
non mimì triturano sì sì sì sì grande
cos'è giovinco si perfetto meno male
dove c'è e tu speri che io mi ricordi
sta cosa aspettate credo sia questo ok
questo fatto sbagliato meno netto a melo
rivedere un attimo
ok 1234 e tutti quanti insieme come
cazzo de premo tutti a fosse così il
city perfetto hai ragione tu
ok allora abbiamo trovato di nuovo
all'inizio stavolta ha tagliato i cavi
stronzo devo cosa devo fare per riunirli
ok adesso accendo la tv quel giorno ci
rivediamo lo stesso
no no no non dico dall'inizio non di
nuovo dall'inizio non ci vota sì esatto
esatto amico mia amica quest'uomo mi
capisce ralf race questo blitz è stato
potuta mente incredibile bello ora tra
l'altro ci sono due e se non sbaglio c'è
anche trevi di ragazzi se vi è piaciuto
fatemi sapere se volete che io faccio
anche quelli che ragazzi 6 video è
piaciuto come al solito lasciato un
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook che come noi di video trovate
nella descrizione se ne senato rischi
iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo in un
prossimo vito beh ragazzi